hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to a growing wish list of
features that we'd like to see in the
next version of android likely android
5.0 i asked a question on twitter
earlier and i got a lot of interesting
responses and if you have something
you'd like to see in the next version of
android feel free to leave that in the
comment section right below that like
button and uh let's go ahead and take a
look at what i would actually like to
see in uh what will probably be called
jelly bean first of all google chrome
i'd love to see google chrome drop the
beta tag and really be integrated with
the actual os and be actually the stock
browser in android 5.0 it's already one
of the best mobile browsers out there
pretty much it has tab sync across
multiple platforms password sync
bookmark sync it's a really really solid
browser and i'd love to see it
really be merged in with the rest of the
operating system uh as it's become quite
an awesome browser even in beta status
on android 4.0 another thing i'd like to
see is you know while hollow is sort of
the overall ui that's been distributed
and is being rolled out to as many apps
as possible i'd like to see the default
android apps have both a dark and a
light theme available there are a couple
of apps for android that are dark themed
already and a couple of apps that are
light themed for example the gmail app
is already light themed and the dialer
app is already dark themed but the
people app kind of sticks out like a
sore thumb as all the rest of the
calling apps are dark themed and people
is sort of a light themed app so i'd
like to have the ability to either like
set a manual like master switch
everything dark or a master switch for
everything light and kind of have the
whole operating system go along with the
way you feel about it there are a lot of
great apps out there that already use uh
that have a switcher where you can
choose from dark or light themes so i
think android could definitely do the
same thing something i'd also like to
see is built-in performance profiles we
already know that there are some
quad-core devices coming out and there
are already dual-core devices that are
doing really well and they tend to be a
little bit short on battery life so you
should have some sort of ability to
change just how well
how highly they are performing at given
times you could have a nighttime mode
which underclocks your processor you
could have a work time mode which is
sort of more interactive maybe an
entertainment mode or a gaming mode
which is more processing power and the
modes could switch either manually or by
like automatically so maybe by location
or by the wi-fi network you're on or by
how much battery you have left something
else cool would be a little bit faster
multitasking ui i'm really a big fan of
the current multitasking ui i think it's
one of the best on any mobile platform
right next to webos
the way that you can flip through cards
and see and end applications on android
is really solid i think it's the only
part of android 4.0 that is a little bit
slow so the next version of android
should hopefully bring performance
increases and speaking of performance
increases quad-core optimization should
be on that list as the next wave the
next generation of processors of phones
that are released in the super phone
category they're going to be quad core
and then there are some little things
like the ability to unlock straight to
an application you know some additional
lock screen functionality i mean that
always brings up privacy concerns people
flipped out over face unlock so you know
google's probably a little bit hesitant
to pull something like that off and also
something small is the ability to zoom
in on an email in the stock gmail app i
swear one of gmail is easily
the best app on android it's one of the
most amazing apps on any mobile platform
but yet you can't zoom in on an image on
in gmail it's just a little bit weird
also ice cream sandwich is only on about
five percent of android devices right
now still most android devices are on
gingerbread and the newer phones that
are coming out they're actually starting
to have android 4.0 now so maybe the
next version of android will be 4.1
seems a little bit more realistic but
other than that yeah i i really like
android and i'm really excited for the
next version of it so go ahead and let
us know what do you think is going to be
in the next version of android or just
what do you want to be in the next
version i mean i could i could list a
thousand things that i want to be in the
next version but that i think what i
just said is a pretty concise list of
what i i think is going to be in the
next version i mean i'd like it to make
me toast and be a roller coaster ride
when i need something to cheer me up but
that's probably not gonna happen either
way thanks for watching guys go ahead
and give this video a thumbs up if you
enjoyed it i'm gonna go ahead and sign
off again here and i'll talk to you guys
in the next video thanks for watching
guys
peace
so
you